hey guys it's justine and today in this
video we're gonna be talking about some
of my favorite highlights from sony's
ces presentation that their ceo gave
during the event now if you guys missed
it no worries i've got you covered
now it's no secret that i'm a huge sony
fan especially when it comes to cameras
movies tvs and gaming but what i really
loved about this presentation was the
bigger picture like their prototype car
the vision s the way that they are
leading the path in virtual production
and sony's drone the air peak so the
last ces that i attended in real life i
got a chance to check out their
prototype of the vision s in person now
since then they've continued to develop
on this concept with more advanced
technology for electric vehicles sony
also unveiled the vision s2 this is a
new suv type prototype vehicle as well
as the establishment of sony mobility i
am so sold on the electric car future so
it's really great to see some of the
possibilities and the ways that sony
sensors their 360 reality audio and all
of their cameras are being integrated
into their vision s now the vision s is
using this beautiful panoramic screen it
has digital side mirrors and
conveniently placed control panels to
minimize eye movement the digital side
mirrors are actually really cool and
it's awesome because it's like it's not
actually a mirror it's digital so it's
like a camera that is showing you what's
behind you so you're not really looking
in a mirror at all sony has such a huge
library of content with music and movies
and these can be implemented into the
screens for backseat entertainment so if
you're in the back seat you can listen
to music you can watch movies and if
you've never experienced 360 reality
audio it is so impressive each of these
seats have their own individual speakers
so it'll create this individual sound
field for each seat even getting a demo
of this car a few years ago it was
actually mind-blowing how amazing it
sounded this concept has 40 sensors
there's 18 cameras 18 radar and four
lidar that are all around the vehicle to
assist with improving the driving
experience now using all of these
sensors it will give you a 360 view
around the car so that'll assist with
things like autonomous parking and lane
changing i feel like i could talk about
this car the entire video but there are
more things to cover like virtual
production okay all right just i'm gonna
sit down for this because i am still
kind of processing how incredible this
is for the future of production this
tech is being implemented into more
shows and movies than i think anyone
even realizes and sony has been leading
this initiative and i got a chance to
check this out in action a few years ago
when they first announced it at ces and
since then it has only gotten better
like okay check this out so instead of
using traditional green screen or even
practical sets these worlds and
environments are being built out
virtually now whether they're building
them out in 3d or actually going out and
filming these environments they're using
sony crystal led tech so they're able to
shoot in front of these displays as if
they're actually in these locations and
this gives you the ability to transport
to exotic locations very quickly and
very easily and i have been on a bunch
of sets when you're out in like the
middle of a desert and the temperature
and just being out in the elements i'm
not gonna lie kind of sucks so this is
something that i'm so excited for and
i'm just gonna say if anybody needs me
to be in any you know upcoming films or
anything hi i'm here i'm ready i'm
available and with the sony venice which
is definitely something that might be a
little bit too high tech for my studio
but i would really love to check one out
this camera is able to maximize the
crystal led with its precise capturing
and it's so exciting to see all of these
behind the scenes shots of how
production is actually getting taken to
the next level when you see these final
movies and tv shows and stuff on your
screen being able to take a step back
and actually see how they're doing it is
really fascinating they also have the
ability to rig these cameras and the
sets so that it'll interact with the
camera movement so the environment will
be able to move realistically if you're
actually there in whatever set that
they've chosen i can only hope to one
day shoot something really cool on one
of these okay also no secret that i'm a
huge fan of drones and i love everything
about them from flying them to editing
the shots that i've got afterwards so
when sony first gave a sneak peek of the
air peak i was so excited and this isn't
really a drone for everyday consumers
but it's definitely targeting more
professional creators it looks pretty
similar to some of the higher end drones
that you may have seen in the past but
all of this tech was developed in-house
by sony to achieve maximum flight
performance all the key components are
originally designed by sony like the
propellers to the motors to the esc it
has superior wind resistance with high
precision sensors and refined flight
algorithm that allows air peak s1 to
accurately determine its environment
location and positioning to keep low
level flight shake to a minimum if
you've ever flown drones especially on
low level kind of ironic that that is
something that i enjoy doing more than
flying them up super high because you're
getting this perspective that is really
difficult to get in any other way than
if you were flying a drone this does
sometimes cause a problem because if you
are filming very low and you're getting
a lot of wind resistance from not only
the drone and the propellers pushing
down on the ground it's definitely a
difficult situation when you're flying
super low so i'm really excited to test
this out this is also currently one of
the world's smallest drones in its class
and it can carry a full-frame alpha
mirrorless camera there is an air peak
flight app that goes with it so it'll
let you adjust camera settings in the
controls it has a dual operation mode so
you'll be able to have someone pilot and
then someone else control the gimbal to
get the right shots there are automated
flight modes like mission flights and
this will let you follow a preset routes
and then you can also do a repeat route
and that will let you retrace a previous
one i think this is really cool because
i feel like there's a lot of times where
there's some really cool things
happening and you want to kind of do
that same shot over and over again and
to try to fly that exactly is pretty
difficult so the fact that you can just
repeat what you just did definitely
excited to try that out speaking of
drones this is wild sony is looking to
actually take flight into space now in
2020 sony launched the sony space
entertainment project in partnership
with the university of tokyo and jaxa to
open up space experiences that usually
were only reserved for astronauts they
just rebranded it to star sphere and on
the show floor at ces they showcased a
full-scale mock-up of the nano satellite
that they are aiming to launch in 2022.
that is supposedly happening this year
it's so awesome it has sony's camera
technology built into it and when it's
paired with the navigational software
the users will be able to adjust camera
settings the angle of the view the
composition of the moon the sun and the
stars all using a shooting simulator
like just can we stop for a minute like
this is flying
essentially a drone i get like in space
it's so mind-blowing to think that this
is the near future like this is
something that is allowing space
exploration to become more accessible to
everyday people so like hi uh sign me up
okay so another highlight was seeing tom
holland talk about his work on the
uncharted movie that is due out in
theaters in february i just love that
this was like an original playstation
game and now it's being brought to life
with tom holland i'm not gonna lie he
might be having a little fan girl moment
i mean he's not even here i mean i've
never even met him i don't even know him
he doesn't even know i exist but i think
this is so freaking exciting i have
loved his portrayal of spider-man so i
cannot wait to see what he does with
nathan drake's character he also said
that to be able to really channel nathan
he played the game a ton to understand
and develop this character art now it's
crazy because if you've ever been on set
or if you've ever heard people talk
about being on set and filming movies
there's a lot of down time i like to say
that sometimes when i'm on a big set for
a big production that i could shoot
about 45 youtube videos in the amount of
time that i've spent
sitting around which means tom may have
had a little bit of downtime to play
some uncharted in the trailer for for
research right we're just going to call
it research either way i am so hyped to
check that out when it's in theaters let
me know in the comments below if you're
excited to see it as well now for those
of us who have been waiting very
patiently to hear about the next version
of the sony playstation vr wait no more
it's here it has new sensory features it
has enhanced controls and tracking the
eye tracking software will actually
allow you to have more control and
interactivity the headset has feedback
so players can feel subtle responsive
feedback it's 4k hdr with 110 degrees
field of view and there's even all new
playstation vr2 sense controllers these
will allow you to feel and interact with
games in a much more visceral way
knowing how much i love the ps5 dual
sense controllers i am so excited to try
out the new playstation vr2 controllers
and the headset as well i'll also just
be here patiently waiting for them to
release more information about it
whenever the time comes i'm gonna be
here just i'm just waiting this is me
waiting
so those are a few of the bigger picture
things from sony that i'm super excited
about i honestly just keep thinking
about virtual production and like what
that's gonna look like for the future
like we basically can go anywhere at any
time in any place and it's gonna just
really change the way that movies and
films and tvs and things are created i
feel like now we have this expectation
to have content turned out way quicker
than it's able to actually be produced
so with things like this we're going to
be getting way more content way quicker
anyway one of the best ways that you
guys can keep up to date with everything
going on in the world of sony is by
checking out square.sony.com
i am definitely super excited about all
of the things that are coming out and i
can't wait to show them to you if you
guys have anything that you'd like to
see me cover here on my channel feel
free to leave it in the comments below
and i will see you guys in the next
video bye
[Music]